This is my favorite kind of ASMR, so if you can bear with me and ask your cup of tea,
I have a hell of a lot of tingles to show you.
I'm basically, I'm not really gonna be editin' out any like bumps and stuff so the audio's
more organic cause some people really like the rambling aspect and like the more, it's
not genuine but when you like hardcore edit something and make it like so professional
sometimes it can lose its charm because like you can hear me bump the microphone or for
example that noise you heard that was my thighs cause I'm currently like sitting on a chair
my legs up like not on the floor but I have an immersive array of kind of like ASMR tingles
to take you there, it's just kind of a little cutesy video I guess you can jump in the background
but like you'll, you'll hear like this kind of noise in the back cause that's my table
and it holds like over, I'm lookin' at it right now, it's probably got like 20 different
tingly things and that's with items because with ASMR you can use your bobo bobo boys
for tingles like repeat triggers or you can fall into the mic like see or I can actually
tap the mic like this or you can do ear goping like I get you know there's so much you can
freakin' do it it's amazing but I saw, I would literally surprise go one by one and just
kind of do a little ear cleaning with a brush this is just a generic, it's actually a brush
that came with Clean Your PC set and thank you to the radio microphone that I have
the silicone ears, they actually sound pretty accurate to what you would hear like if you
press your actual ears and in real life you can hear the do do do like da da da da
hopefully I'm making sense but this is just this generic, general ear brush and you know
everyone, instead of everyone chase, everyone has different tingles so I may do something
that's not really for you but this is kind of a quick, fire type of ASMR session so
don't you worry if you're like that sounds awful strongy, it's a lot to say awful
or maybe I should do a guest tingles, okay you'll never actually guess what this is
hear it, okay this is against your ear
if anyone said sponge, congrats I'm coming down, yeah because I don't even know how you would guess that's a sponge
honestly it just sounds like a crisp packet
did you tingle, did you, did you, did you, that's right, tingle harder for me
and okay, like I'm gonna be honest, you guys are probably like, you should probably use
grips all the time and a bloody should because this is for hands, I get too excited
and then I break the freaking sound barrier because I'm gonna have to put a filter on this audio
so I'm not like going to lift what other tingles have I got
okay, listen to this right, this is, this is on here, it's a cotton ball but if I shove it in your ear canal
listen to this
please help me you're tingling
some people as fast as them are does well sometimes
but I feel like I've, I've, I've attempted to make it in the past right
but whenever I've done it I feel like I'm taking the best because like it's more supposed to be like nice
and slow and relaxing here
so if I just shove up and go
how the fuck are you supposed to tingle for that, like honestly come with me
anyway, do you hear this, this is a plastic, plastic, uh, a silicon ball
there's tons of other silicon balls inside it
and if I press it against your ear it sounds like you're under water with me
yeah look, because I'm a gottlefish, uh uh uh, okay
oh yeah
it's like a chair, I don't know what it is
you like my putting that against your ear
hmm
oh yeah
I admit I cooked with that one
I found it in the thrush shop
and I think I must say it's also a smartest use
it's always like I actually don't want to use that sound so when I look for one
and I found out, I think this is probably like one of those 10, 10 tingles for me
there's some tingles that are like, sorry I'm gonna have to stand up to grab the next item
because, what the fuck was that noise?
so many
oh, I'll tell you all the popular ones
hair brushing is always popular
this is my, the pins on the brush, like peep peep peep
do you remember when Emmy's code name was pins?
hey hey hey
you guys all guessed she was a fiddle
but she's my fiddle doll
wow
do you remember when my code name went inks?
and then I call all you comments that are like
oh it's gonna be weird getting used to your name being so droney
but I feel like it just made sense
because obviously I got to name everyone
and I quite like literal names
this is just me being like babaga
but if like, feature verse come out and their names are like
you know, bag of gaijin at the end when their English is being feature verse
and my name is gonna remember your name
oh, and then this is me being really hypocritical
because obviously I started naming them after French, right?
just a quick front there
I'm called Coles because I'm a Coles
she be is literal because she's Shabari
she be, and then Colvin Bump because she has a tail
so she has Colin on her bum
Emmy bees, oh, you know what, I've just said the most hypocritical thing
because Emmy's name is Japanese and French
her name means family because
you know what, I'm gonna speak it back to the ASMR
because this is just me being a silly dude with
okay, so you can have like
earphones on the microphone like
but there are also
tools and apparatuses to make such a noise
so either this will be too fast to enjoy
but you
trying to make it too loud
that's actually a really big behind the scenes thing
that I have to like stop talking
and then do the tingle and then lure over the actual video
because some tingles are just far too loud
to do at the same time stalking
and then again it takes away from the organic appeal
of the video but like it's just kind of
the cookie crumbles in the nicest way
I'm bumping fucking everything by the way
okay
so you hear me touch this
sounds better all along
what could it be
oh, fuck that up
it's like one of them frogs
he's actually a bit loud
look, I'm not really a big fan
I can tap a slow feet with a wood
and the wee wood thing actually likes that much more than
what the perky was designed for
the hail, you know what
unironically though
that's life, like you could be
you're responding to do one thing
but you're better at another thing, you know
so don't feel the pressure to be this thing that you're not
wow, we're getting philosophical
and I'm smacking a wooden frog with a stick
but I'm actually being for real though
that's actually kind of true because I'll say this
over and over again
I have problems reading and writing
my entire income and job is being paced around
reading and writing
so like, I'm not ever embarrassed about it
like, if you've ever watched me in a live stream
whenever I'd write something I have to read it for it to clear
like, if I wanted to spell A.C.'s name
her name is an I-C-E-Y
her name is I-C-E-Y-A
like, I would say it
I'm like, I'm not even embarrassed about it
who gives a rat's fucking arms
oh, this is a Japanese ear cleaning tool
I love, love, I love this trigger so much
don't worry, I'm gonna subtitle this video
I love this trigger so freaking much
it's so good and fluffy
and like, you can hear
as well, actually, while I've got you here
I'm gonna show you the difference between an ear cleaner
and a Japanese tool, if I'm not mistaken
ear cleaner, okay, got it, got it, got it
okay
hold on, hold on
okay, I have three different things on my hand right now
this is Japanese ear cleaning tool
right
and then this one is
I want to do your most comment
this one's an ear cleaner
this is a Q-tip to Americans
you see how it's different
and then one more ear cleaning thing
this is a cotton pad
which is used for makeup removal in the ear
now an argument
okay, I just realized
I'm leaving your other ear out, forgive me
I'm so focused
but to hear the deepness
that was the cotton pad
I prefer deep ASMR sounds
I find them relaxing
and all that jazz
but I will say the Japanese ear cleaning tool
is so superior
like, I can't even find any
and that's like, I would give it a 10 out of 10
definitely
oh, there's another 10 out of 10 organ I was saying
this is just like, literally a dropper bowl
yeah, peach
I don't have any liquid in that
maybe you can help me along with like
that's terrible, that's terrible
this is for tingling, this is for peachy
peachy 13, okay
we have some people who like
medical sounds, like medical role play
and the level dropper bowl is like a pretty good
because like, sometimes an ASMR sound
doesn't even have to be something that is a tool of it
where the heck is me
and I've lost me glove
I've got a little glove that I like to use
I think it makes like a really good sound
like, tell me, tell me it doesn't sound like you're in the nurse's office right now
like, come on
if I can get a one
are you ready for your prostate in my chin?
but yeah, I definitely like the latex
but like, in combination with the dropper
got to feel it mercy actually
no fingerprints, no traces left
got this, this is just me
just promoting everyone
then he made me, I think they blow off
unless
can I take your tapping on glove on?
I think it does look like a nice
I'm a bit, I'm a bit biased, a bit partial
I wouldn't say latex gloves are a 10 out of 10 tingle
but I would say they rank awfully high
okay, this one
I hope you didn't hear that
I hope I didn't ruin it
this one's a 10 out of 10
how
how much 10 out of 10
the problem with these
is you have to do it slowly
but you're against gravity
because like, if I just do it really quick
that's not tingly, is it?
get a t-fuck if it's tingly
must not make such a sound right now
did you hear that turtle for?
but here you have to slow
it's definitely a good one
isn't it?
one more
I want to read, baby
what is all this going to do, ASMR or is that a purple one?
no, this is lab ASMR
of course I'm purple
okay, actually
that was so loud
don't worry, I'll edit it in post-production
so it doesn't break your ears
but that broke my ears
because I can hear myself into the microphone
I use a Tascam to capture it
I'm in a recording booth
but it's such a waste of fucking money
but you can still hear me
I've put earmuffs on you
Vicky
I like this sound
I like this sound because it's so soft
I think the deeper noises
this is an example of a deeper noise tingle
that definitely has my
appreciation
because
when it's like soothing and deeper
like this is my theory
but you didn't have to believe me
you didn't have to, it's just me
because it's just me, the original
but I think ASMR
is also locked into
you don't want a baby to come soon
and you have to like
get soothed by like really loud noises
and all of that
I think that comfort
possibly is linked to the
comfort that ASMR can bring
not the tingles, not the tingles
but the comfort
which is why these deeper noises
are so unbelievably soothing
because that was
literally the first like
state of
just pure bliss, you know
like when you were in your most
tummy
you didn't have to pay taxes
you didn't have to
like any work
or even a concert
you just sat there
and you were like
who should give you all the nutrients
and you passed like shit
to the political court
I mean god
what could you ask for more in life
but that's my Thomas theory what I know T
I just don't know much about
you know what
just because you don't know something
doesn't mean you can't
you can't make a statement
that's wrong and loud ok
I raised my case
this is where I make my stand
I'm looking over the mic now
to see if there's other triggers
I've messed up on and there is
if I can teach it
don't make me
just making you notice
ok I know I did brush in earlier
but I actually have another brush
compared to this brush I used earlier
like right
but this is a makeup brush
this one and it's so much softer
so soft
I do that's another point as well
so you don't have to only use
some more trigger
doing two at the same time
is like so good
so that's one with a brush
and the other just
my hand going over the ear
and I'm going
I'm not that good at doing triggers
I have a really spitty mouth
like I'm self-failing on and off
so it makes it a bit hard to do
like so then vocal
like talking ASMR because my mouth
always clicks like
with spit
and I don't think it's very easy
and I know I don't get me wrong
there's things called D-Clicker
which it first can like use to get rid of
but mine is like
so fake it's wrong I just rather
restart my whole sentence
you've never noticed there's like
none in this video in particular
but probably much more likely in other videos
there'll be like a cut
my mood just slightly shifts
because I've had to resource it
because my mouth won't stop
going go go go go
and clicking
wait please give me a break
I'm tired
I'm tired boss
okay what else
I'm pretty sure I saw a few others
um
alright
that was a good one
one is like some professional
um
okay this one is
a cup
like it's literally just a plastic ass cup
but the reason why I like it
is because
if I put it over your ear
that sounds like fucking shit
it sounds so much better in person
I'm just gonna have to come here
to show you how much that was awful
okay this is an old
plastic phone case
so
you know you can do fingerprint
it's more like this is just my finger
being pressed against it
like in like the
the center of my skin
um or
obviously you can do your little nails
against it
and uh
just
whatever your amounts is
I hope this has been enough for
I feel like I've just yapped a bit
I'm so unmasked in our time
I'm just
I'm just gonna have to lure and edit the volume
under the case that I've made an ASMR audio
and the reality is
it's just another yap this from
here's truly
honestly I prefer to act quite
like this one
when I say it's a 10 out of 10
I think you know what
I've had fake nails on and like
the would hit a bit better
cause
cause fake nails like give that availability
of just sounding
better in more
but
I also have this
fluffy thing that I can put on
against the
ear
but yes I'll talk to you on that
so you'll be able to sound like
often on my ear
and thank you
all of you baby
I'll listen to some people like
when they can hear my breathing
so
I don't
fuck
I guess breathing can be so
like I used
to get my eyelashes done
and the lady obviously had to be in
close proximity
and she would just be turning and I'd
like
because she was just like near me breathing
and I'm like I'm at a weird door
for getting tingles from breathing ASMR
but
it is what it is
you don't pick the tingles
the tingles pick you
what else am I going to
I'm sure of course I don't know
sorry I was scratching my thigh there
I have some like
it's not really
not tingling this is a
plastic pouch
it has a little click
oh that size is breaking
my sound barrier
oh dear
that one didn't
if you didn't know the task gun
will flash red
like
if I'm being too loud
it's like oh my god your tingles
are out of control lady
and so I know
when I'm being a bit too loud
but I can't see the task gun
in like every recording session
it's just not possible because of my setup
although I don't know if I should record
on my pc
but
yeah I'm toying
maybe you like plastic
fingerprints
actually sounds pretty sticky
actually kind of like that
yeah you like my sticky
fingers being on you
now there is
an ASMR
this noise
is really hard to capture
I have
two
wooden ear picks
but wooden ear picking ASMR
is really fake and hard to capture
it's just because
it sounds like I'm
fingering your ear or something
this one actually do have to like
focus a little bit on your ear
but either this is
good or just kind of sounds like
I'm brushing some around on my ear
but
I promise
I have two wooden ear picks
oh I can maybe
add tweezers
hold on
some people like tweezers
sounds but
that's the only sound they make
they don't like make a natural sound
I think
for visual ASMR
I would make some visual ASMR
and I can show you many
else
cause I like
my nails so
yeah for you
well yes
mister
your ears are delightfully clean
but there's nothing
that
is bad what
sounds I'm going with here
try to see your ears are clean
but I'll just clean them further
which makes no sense
but that's okay
I'm allowed to be dumb
and I
forgive myself
yeah
you like the way those ear picks and tweezers
feel that's right
no
I mean
I would say I did a decent
thing over here
how long have we been recording for
I have no idea
how long have I been there in minutes
I've been yapping for 30 minutes
why have you left me yapping for so long
what the hell
how has it been 30 minutes
oh my god I've got problems
seriously
I mean maybe it's less
but because I had to edit some stuff
I hope
I'm leaving my tummy noises in
so
hopefully
you're asleep by now
and if you're not then
I'll be hearing so many awful eyes away
and
I'll just put it away
for a little bit
I don't know
okay
wait I'm sure I had a few more tangles
wait don't go yet don't leave
I want to show you more
okay
I see
I said I see
no I say
I said I say snow pose
I said I see visually
okay I'll call it three more triggers
and then I'll let you go
okay I'll let you go
you do it in the ear
okay
okay you heard me move one of them
but don't
this one
it's like a little
water thing
and I can just
that went on my face
I didn't realize it was pointed on me
so
I can't do it against the ears a little bit
but you know
no one wants to put water in your very
expensive equipment
this equipment was expensive
was it worth it? I don't know yet
but yeah
oh yeah
oh I can do it
oh
yeah
oh you feel so refreshed
listen up to this ASMR
okay the other one
this one's quite loud so I might not talk
too much during it because I'll need to lower
the volume
but I got
pop rocks I'm not going to do it
but like I'm going to shake the packet
of the pop rocks
I'm not being funny I was so
unbelievably loud
okay last angle
and this one's a 10 out of 10 for me
okay
you can totally hear it actually
oh oh oh
are you ready?
see
so
why did you think
I was double
ASMR and it's like
what's one of my top 10's as well
But if you're not asleep by now, I'm not sure what I can do.
Um, I could keep down that tingle until you are asleep.
Would that be fine?
Like, I wouldn't talk anymore.
Cause I feel like if I keep talking, this was keeping you awake.
Cause you're like, what's the next tingle, strongy?
Um, right, I'll make you a deal.
You close your eyes, you're nice and comfy.
I will keep tickling you to prove that tickling ASMR is like one of the superior triggers.
Because like, breathing is good and all like,
or, but I think tickling in this case, okay, I just need to prove it's superior.
So, I'll let you go now.
But thank you for listening to me rubble for 30 minutes.
Cause I eat always 30, 5 minutes.
Okay, jish, jish, my shish.
Okay, I'll let you go.
And I'm going to tickling ASMR.
And I'll see you on the other side, okay?
Bye.
Can I do it?
I'm going to let you do ASMR ear kiss.
Just one, just one kiss, okay?
But what ear should I do it on?
This one.
And this one.
I feel biased to this ear.
Good night.